Now it's important to understand how the application
cache works together with the http cache. When we
say that the cache is downloaded or Appcache updates
the files of the cache, those downloads are still
following the rules of http caching. If those files
are already in the http cache, they may come
from that cache rather than over the network. You
can still use far-future caching, for example, on files
that you know won't change often, and when
the Appcache update system needs a new copy of
them, it'll pull them out of the http
cache, not grab them over the network. This gives
you a two-stage updating system, which can be pretty useful. However,
there is one file that you should never far-future cache. What is it? The
master HTML page? The manifest file? Or cat videos?